الى تطورات حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا حيث
حذرت القياده العسكريه الجنوبيه في الجيش
الاوكراني من ان القوات الفروسيه تدفع
بسفن اضافيه الى البحر الاسود محمله
بصواريخ من نوع
واضافت ان احتمال وقوع هجوم صاروخي نطاق
على نطاق مقاطعه اوديس والمقاطعات
الجنوبيه الاخرى يزداد خطوره داعيه السكان
الى التزام التعليمات وما يصدر من تنبيهات
جويه واشارت القياده الى وجود اربع سفن
روسيه محمله بصواريخ كاليبر في مهمه
قتاليه بالبحر الاسود في حين اقتصر التحرك
القتالي امس على سفينتين
وفي مقاطعه خرسون قال المتحدث باسم القوات
الجويه الاوكرانيه
ان القوات الروسيه تستخدم قنابل مواجهه
على طول خط الجبهه في خرسون واضاف اجناد
ان تلك القنابل تشكل تهديدا روسيا جديدا
على حده وصفه
[موسيقى]
يستخدم الغزاه القنابل الموجهه على طول خط
الجبهه باكمله وبدات الطائرات الروسيه
باطلاق نحو 20 قنبله بوزن 500 كيلوغرام
يوميا والاعتراض تلك القنابل نحتاج الى
صواريخ مضاده للطائرات هناك تهديد كبير
للتعامل مع القنابل الموجهه لاننا ببساطه
لا نمتلك ما يكفي من الاسلحه لمواجهتها
ونبقى في مقاطعه خرسون اذ قالت الاداره
العسكريه الاوكرانيه ان الروس قصف عموم
اراضي المقاطعه الجنوبيه خلال ساعات
الماضيه نحو 78 مره ب 360 قذيفه استهدفت
بشكل اساسي الاحياء السكنيه والبنيه
التحتيه المدنيه اما هيئه الاركان
الاوكرانيه فافادت عن استمرار القصف
الروسي على مقاطعه
مستهدفا البنيه التحتيه في زفروجيا ماوقع
قتلى وج رحى عن تدمير مباني سكنيه واشارت
الى ان الروس يواصلون بناء خطوط ومواقع
دفاعيه في المقاطعتين الجنوبيتين تحسبا
لاي هجوم مضاد من القوات الاوكرانيه واكد
الجيش الاوكراني تنفيذه ضربات على المواقع
الروسيه واسقاطه سته طائرات من دون طيار
الى محور دنيتك حيث افادت وكاله سبوتنيك
الروسيه ان القوات الاوكرانيه اطلقت اكثر
من 100 مقذوف خلال ساعات الماضيه واكد
سلطات المواليه لروسيا ان القصف الاوكراني
استهدفت خلال اليوم الماضي مناطق سكنيه
مختلفه واسفر عن اصابات بين المدنيين
واضرار في بعض المباني السكنيه
اما في مقاطعه فقالت هيئه الاركان
الاوكرانيه ان قتلى وجرحى سقطوا في قصف
روسي على مناطق عده وافادت الاداره
العسكريه الاوكرانيه في مقاطعه خرسون ان
القوات الروسيه قصفت اجزاء من اراضي
المقاطعه الجنوبيه خلال ساعات الماضيه في
المقابل اكد الجيش الاوكراني ان قواته
استهدفت مواقع تمركز الافراد والعتاد
الروسي خلال الساعات الماضيه واسقطت سته
طائرات مسيره وقصفت اربعه مجمعات صواريخ
مضاده للطائرات
متابعه لهذا الوضع واخر مستجداته من
الميدان معنا من دنيا مراسل الجزيره بابا
والحرمه ومن كلاب مراسل الجزيره تامر
صمادي ابدا معك بابا ولد حرمه عن جديد
الوضع التطورات عده سوف تعلقه منها بدون
ايسك او ما جرى في
نعم عبد القادر اخر تطوراتها الميدانيه هو
اعلان مركزيه الرصد هنا في دنيا وهو هيئه
محليه ان تعرضه حييني في المدينه لقصف هما
وكذلك
دون ان يقدمها تفاصيل بشان تبعتي هذا
القصف
في عده احياء في المدينه من بينها مثلا
في مدينه ياسين وكذلك في
مقاطعه
على جبهه
القائم باعمال الحكومه المحليه في دنيا
كالمواليه لروسيا دانيس يتحدث عن ما
يقولوا انه التقدم تحرزه قوه
في هذه المدينه وكذلك يقول ان هناك دمار
واسعا تعيش هذه هي المدينه التي كانت
مسرحا لمواجهه محتدمه بين اخواتي وفقنا
روسيا وبين القوات الاوكرانيه يقول هذا
المسؤول الموالي يقول ان هناك تقدم تحيزه
القوات الروسيه وانه هناك زحفا لهذه
القوات من جهه متعدده صوب الجزئي الغربيه
الذي مازال تحت سيطره القوات الاوكرانيه
حتى الان ميدانيا تتحدث وزاره الدفاع
تحدثت قبل قليل عن اسقاط الطائره مسيره من
طرف
القوات من طرف انظمه الانظمه المضاده
للطيران في منطقه كرسني
الشمالي من جبهتها القتال بين الجانبين
الروسي والاوكراني وزاره الدفاع تتحدثت
خلال اليوم الماضي كذلك عما قالت انها
اضرار بالغه لحقتها بالقوه الاوكرانيه
سواء في الانفوس تتحدث عن 400 قتيل في
صوفيا القوات الاوكرانيه والقوات
الاوكرانيه على طول جبهتها الحدود تتحدث
كذلك عن استهداف مستودع
الوقود في منطقه تقول ان القوات
الاوكرانيه كانت تستخدمه في تلك المنطقه
لتحريك الياتها ومدرعاتها العسكريه من
القاده العسكريين الاوكرانيين من تحرك
لقطع بحريه روسيه في البحر الاسود في
وضعيه الهجوم والمستهدف اوديس
بالتاكيد المستهدف في اوديسا والمقاطعات
الجنوبيه وفقا للاداره العسكريه
الاوكرانيه في اوديسيا والقياده قياده
عمليات الجنوب الاوكرانيه عبد القادر وهو
ما اشاره اليه بشكل واضح صباح هذا اليوم
تحدثت عن مزيد من القطع البحريه العسكريه
التي تصل تباعا للقوات الروسيه من شبه
جزيره القرم باتجاه البحر الاسود وتحدثت
خلال ساعات الماضيه عن اكثر من اربعه سفن
متواجده في البحر الاسود محمله بصواريخ
كاليبر مجنحه القياده الجنوبيه الاوكرانيه
قالت بان هذه الصواريخ مهيئه للاطلاق في
اي لحظه على التي ظلت يعني هادئه خلال
الايام الاخيره الى حد كبير وهو ما دفع
السلطات هناك الى تنبيه المواطنين بضروره
الالتزام بالتنبيهات الجويه وقالت باننا
امام خطر قد يكون كبير يشمل كافه مقاطعات
الجنوب التي تتعرض لقصف متواصل في طيله
الساعات الماضيه وطيله الايام الماضيه
والحديث هنا تحديدا عن اشار اليها الرئيس
الاوكراني هنا في كياب خلال الساعات
الماضيه وقال بانها تتعرض لقصف مكثف من
قبل السلطات القوات الروسيه وكانت هيئه
الاركان تحدثت الاوكرانيه بالتاكيد بطبيعه
الحال عن ان القصف الروسي المتواصل على
الذي يطال البنيه التحتيه بالاضافه الى
العديد من المناطق الماهوله بالسكان ادى
خلال الساعات القليله الماضيه الى قتلى
وجرحى وايضا هذا القصف المتواصل على
جبروجيا يطال ايضا خيرسون خلال الساعات
الماضيه تحدثت ايضا هيئه الاركان والقياده
العسكريه في خرسون عن عشرات العمليات التي
نفذتها القوات الروسيه كقصف بالمدفعيه
بقذائف الهاون بالصواريخ ايضا على العديد
من المناطق في خرسون والحديث عن
القرى الواقعه على طول خط التماس في خرسون
والتي تعاني قصفا مستمرا طيله الايام
الماضيه الحديث ايضا عن قتلى وجرحى وقصف
خلال الدقائق الاخيره طاله احد المراكز
التابعه للحكومه في قلب المدينه خرسون لكن
في الحقيقه عبد القادر كانت هنالك يعني
تصريح مهم او كان هنالك تصريح مهم قبل
قليل لامين عام المجلس القومي الاوكراني
الذي تحدث عن الهجوم المضاد للقوات
الاوكرانيه وقال بان هذا الهجوم يتواصل كل
يوم وانه لا توجد تواريخ سحريه لهذا
الهجوم وهو في اشاره الى الحديث المتكرر
طيله الفتره الماضيه عن هجوم الربيع وهجوم
الصيف من قبل القوات الاوكرانيه يقول بانه
يجب التكتم على هذه المعلومات ومفاجاه
القوات الروسيه وبالتاكيد المعركه الاشرس
نهايه هي في باخموت حيث تقول السلطات
الاوكرانيه بانها ما زالت تسيطر على الوضع
هناك لكن المعارك شرسه وشرسه جدا بين
القوات الاوكرانيه والروسيه
شكرا جزيلا لكما